a growing number of Republicans are
encouraging Americans to get vaccinated
despite misinformation spread by
right-wing commentators Louisiana
Congressman Steve scalise the number two
house Republican announced yesterday
that he has received his first Pfizer
shot telling the Louisiana news site
nola.com that the vaccines are safe and
effective our lead National
correspondent David begno is that Our
Lady of the Lake Medical Center in Baton
Rouge Louisiana where there's been a
surge in cases David good morning
Anthony good morning this is the largest
hospital in the state in terms of bed
space and they have more coveted
patients here than any other Hospital in
the state
get this over the weekend they admitted
23 coveted patients in a 24-hour period
how big of a deal is that they filled an
entire floor of the hospital with 24
people an entire floor we were given
unprecedented access to one of the coven
units in order to speak to some of the
patients
honest to God thought I walked my last
day on this Earth
I could not breathe I just all of a
sudden my lungs just didn't work Paula
Johnson was rushed here by ambulance I
have no comment comorbidities
nothing and it took my lungs and just
whoo
I don't even know how to explain it it's
like it's like trying to breathe in and
hitting the wall
in like a second Johnson is a
pharmaceutical researcher who put off
getting the covet vaccine but now she
wants it I'd say get the vaccine
take the chance
it can't hurt all it can do is alleviate
some of the symptoms even if it doesn't
keep you from getting it it'll at least
help you get through it roughly one in
three louisianians are fully vaccinated
this week the state's Health Department
reported the highest number of covid-19
hospitalizations since late February
Scott Rowe is one of them here I am
recovering getting out of here finally
tomorrow am I going to get a vaccine no
um why not
because there's too many issues with
these vaccines this father former
baseball coach small business owner and
Hunter caught covet and then he
developed pneumonia before you got sick
if you would have had a chance to get
the vaccine and prevent this would you
have taken the vaccine
so you'd have gone through this I've
gone through this yes sir don't shove it
down my throat
that's what's
local
state federal Administration is trying
to do to shove it down your throat what
are they shoving the science no they're
showing the fact that that's their
agenda the agenda is to get you
vaccinated you know who Mr scalise is I
know who Steve's place is very well Roe
who is a republican had not heard that
Steve scalise the second ranking house
Republican in Congress had stepped into
the Forefront yesterday as a vaccine
proponent we asked him to read the
congressman statement he thinks it's
safe and effective
and what's your reaction
not proven but does his opinion change
yours no he does not we are either going
to get
get or we are going to accept death Dr
Catherine O'Neill chief medical officer
at Our Lady of the Lake Regional Medical
Center here in Baton Rouge does not
mince words we're a proud state
we are a state of people full of grit so
if you're provax you're going to tell
everybody if you're not you're going to
do the same thing so how do we help find
something that helps them come to the
understanding that your community is
going to die
Dr O'Neill made the point when it comes
to talking to vaccine hesitant or even
anti-vaxx folks you can't stop talking
to them she said David you can't talk
down to them you can't talk Adam but
you've got to keep talking telling them
the stories of the people who are sick
in this hospital and sticking solely
to the facts
very good advice thank you very much
David